All right, guys, we have to get ahead of a
major propaganda story that is breaking today
and happening exactly as predicted.
I have no special psychic insight.
I just knew it was going to happen because
we understand how Donald Trump operates.
We have received the estimated third quarter
GDP number for the United States and annualized
GDP growth for Q3 was an astounding, incredible
thirty three point one percent GDP growth.
Wow.
And if you look at just that number at a superficial
level, turn your brain off, throw logic into
the trash and do no research whatsoever.
You might say this country is doing unbelievably
well economically.
We are back.
Wow.
This is unbelievable.
And you are going to get hit by some insane
propaganda from Donald Trump and his campaign
in the next five days leading up to the election,
which will try to convince you of exactly
that.
It is B.S. and you must be prepared for it.
So GDP changes are relative to the prior status
quo of the GDP.
Remember that in the second quarter, due to
coronavirus, U.S. GDP dropped more than 31
percent.
That's a record we have never had as big a
GDP decrease as we had in the second quarter
of this year.
So when we say GDP is up 33 percent in the
third quarter, it is up relative to the record
decline that we had in the second quarter
before this year.
The biggest ever decrease to the GDP was in
1921.
Second quarter of twenty eight point six percent.
The biggest increase was actually 40 percent
in 1879 Q4.
The country was very different then.
It's not even really relevant to compare that,
but.
OK, and just as I predicted three months ago,
when the second quarter numbers came out,
Donald Trump tweeted this morning exactly
what I told you he would.
I've been preparing you for this for three
months.
Donald Trump tweeting, quote, GDP number just
announced the biggest and best in the history
of our country and not even close next year
will be fantastic.
However, sleepy Joe Biden and his proposed
record setting tax increase would kill it
all.
So glad this great GDP number came out before
November 30.
He is glad.
So let's understand what's going on here.
Be armed with the numbers.
If you work for me, imagine I hire you to
be my, you know, hype man or woman or whatever,
and I pay you a salary of fifty thousand dollars
a year.
OK, if after the first year I give you a 31
percent cut that lowers your salary salary
from fifty thousand dollars a year to thirty
four thousand five hundred, and then the next
year I say, hey, I'm going to give you a 33
percent raise.
This is a huge record raise.
I've never given anybody a 33 percent raise.
You're going to get it.
And after the 31 percent cut and the 33 percent
raise, you are actually still well below your
original salary of fifty thousand dollars.
Now, this is exactly what they're doing here.
There are people who do not understand math
who think, well, we went down 31 percent and
up 33 percent.
We're back.
We're better than ever.
We're recovered.
But of course, that's not the case.
Remember that if something goes down 50 percent,
it then needs to go up 100 percent to get
back to where we were.
I mean, just let's apply this to make it easy
to the number one hundred which we're putting
up on the screen.
If you start with a hundred and lose thirty
one percent, you're down to sixty nine.
That's easy.
If you then get 33 percent back from that
69, you're only up to about 91.
So you are still about eight and a half percent
below where you started.
So now, six months after the end of the first
quarter, we had the second quarter and the
third quarter and we are still down eight
point to three percent from where we started
on April 1st.
This is a stunning economic contraction.
And case in point, the GDP after this explosive
record setting growth that Donald Trump is
bragging about, our GDP is now back up to
where it was two and a half years ago in the
first quarter of.
2018.
You are going to get hit very, very hard with
propaganda and talking points.
But now you understand the math of it.
One of the ways that the right distorts reality
is to ignore the recent past.
And if you look just at Q three.
Wow.
33 percent up.
But that's only if you ignore the second quarter.
I'm not expecting the media to highlight this
and to make it clear.
And you need to come armed with the information
yourself, because this is Trump's last stand.
Folks, 80 million people have already voted.
We have five days until the election.
This is I told you this would be the last
ditch effort to say we did it.
Don't fall for it.
Don't let other people fall for it.
Friends don't let friends fall for obviously
bad math.
That's GDP.
Let's now talk about corona virus and the
stock market.